here's a peek at what guests had to say
after the show okay we're back Larry
Miller question for you who's a guest
you'd like to have on your podcast in
the future I don't have guests but if I
didn't have guests always nice to meet a
fan huh you don't have guests that's
right I've listened to your pocket
that's amazing the verbal drives to be
able to just talk like that
you must think very highly of yourself
learn Barney Frank do you feel more
liberated being out of Congress oh you
must
oh absolutely yeah you don't have to
worry that when the phone rings did
somebody who's screwed something up and
says it's my responsibility to unscrew
it you know you were in a fairly safe
district you were not one of those
Congress people who have to worry about
every little thing you could come on
this show and sit next to a pot-smoking
atheist and it wouldn't bother you if I
which punch smoking atheist were you
talking about my governor will appoint
me to a yes Senate I wish I had two and
I was looking forward to having my
husband Jim hold the Constitution not
the Bible and affirm not swear that I
was going to be right wonderful senator
you would have been a wonderful senator
man
you you an Elizabeth Warren both there
that would have been quite a team well
we can only dream
Josh will scandal such as winners be
more common in politics now because of
the way we use the Internet oh
absolutely
there's no gay man under 35 with a
smartphone who doesn't have pictures
floating out there that he would worry
about showing up on Gawker Thea ran for
mayor of New York what do you say gay
men it's well it's a lot of straight
people too but I think it's you know
it's II it's even it's even more
prevalent even more prevalent no can I
just note that I'm 73 and I have a flip
film okay so Barney can still be mayor
of New York
now he's 58 he has a rotary phone they
got a rotary phone after they were along
God because it made you feel I start
every call by saying Watson come in here
I need you okay which is more concerning
government tracking your online
information or corporations doing the
same thing that's a good question I
would say government's by a hair they
have the potential is words for
government but the day-to-day abuse is
so far have been on the corporate side
I think people worry too much about what
corporations are doing with their data
because I think most of the data about
you is actually not very interesting I
mean when Gmail came out people were
freaked out that they were gonna look
through your emails ran algorithms
show you ads that were relevant based on
that that seems marginally useful to me
I mean I'm still don't click on the ads
but it's not like this computer is
sifting through my emails and then
calling my business about people being
denied bank accounts sure it has to do
with it there are confidential
information there being firm a huge step
they used to be able to raise your
interest rate on money you already owe
the credit card company if somebody else
reported you owed something we outlawed
that but in the financial area there
have been a pattern of abuses alright
Barney what do you think about Elizabeth
Warren's and John McCain's proposal to
reinstate glass-steagall well that's a
big one I don't think it gets that our
problems for example the bad loans that
were made the mortgage loans could as
Segal didn't affect those many of them
made by non banks the biggest problem
was as opposed to 40 is
go when glass-steagall was in effect
they changed and people made loans and
then sold the loan called securitized so
I didn't care whether the person was
gonna pay back or not the whole
derivatives issue glass-steagall the big
mistake was in 2000 when Congress voted
I didn't
- totally deregulate derivatives that
was a that was the most serious problem
and that's the key issue now is to get
the derivatives regulated but but when
glass-steagall went away was it 99 it
was the Clinton right I mean isn't that
really when they let the dogs out no I
when the banks just took your money -
they voted against that but
securitization for example which is
really I think the single worst problem
forty years ago
you borrowed money from a person you had
to pay back and if you're gonna have to
pay me back I'm gonna frisk you pretty
good and then they came up with
securitization in the 80s where all
these loans were made by people who
didn't care whether you paid up in fact
they they sold that loan then these
ridiculous rating agencies told people
it was worth something when it wasn't
this is what dodd-frank got rid of yes
we got rid of the there's now what we
call risk retention if you were gonna
sell a package of loans you and they got
to put this rule out soon
you take the first 5% of the losses so
that you no longer can can do this
lending for free plus we banned the
works kind of the loans because there
was no more incentive for the borrower
for the lender not to make them so those
two things we did and the other thing
was well there's three people made bad
loans than other people sold them and
then other people insured them right but
it defaults right against them we we
have cracked down on that substantially
as well you think that teabaggers know
when they
well when John Boehner says you know I
hate regulations they know that
regulation is a word that means I'm
making rules so you don't get robbed I
don't think they do but securitization
was sort of financially engineered out
of investment banks and glass-steagall
is about separating investment banks
from commercial people both making those
bad loans so separating them that one
was making the bed won't you other was
selling them I think a lot of this
misses the big issue I mean I was a
banker during this period in 2006-2007
so I was part of your problem but but
well actually I really wasn't part of
the rock mikeandgem because I was at
Wells Fargo which is a company that had
a relatively healthy attitude toward
credit and was you know and holds on to
its loan yeah the banks were doing the
securitization they still failed because
you you have this pipeline and you
haven't sold everything off yet so the
people who are like supposed to have
been saying well I don't care because I
don't have any of the risk those people
lost all their Merrill Lynch I think the
problem is just people got crazy about
the idea that real estate could only get
more valuable and so it was safe to lend
as much money doing it again by the way
is you is you need to make people have
equity you need to make homeowners have
equity and you need to make banks have
equity yeah I said one one different you
yes yeah they did wind up losing their
money the problem was they didn't think
they would right exactly because they it
turns out selling the loans and not
having to worry about repayment wasn't
as foolproof as they thought right but
it it emboldened them to go and do the
wrong thing the other thing we did by
the way is just to ban those kind of
loans you can't make loans anymore to
people who can't possibly pay them
except the Obama administration wants a
weakening of lending standards because
they want more people buying houses I'd
sort of the bankers I agree but it's in
the statute there's only a certain
amount of cattitude it's pretty tough
last question Alex does you get it do
you feel that the word protest has
become negative in the US as opposed to
Europe where protests are seen in a more
positive light I certainly think Europe
has stronger protest culture than the
United States but I think the Texas
state legislature I think moral Mondays
in North Carolina what's happening with
the dream defenders in the state capitol
in Tallahassee I think protest has a
really good connotation right now in
this country my problem is it they don't
do it in the right way
sitting in rick scott's office isn't
gonna hurt him at all I am for toughness
on the part of the advocates but that
means going into these people's
districts organizing and going after
them having marches and protests in
general unfortunately I wish it had more
of an impact doesn't if in fact we put
it this way if you are a politician and
the people who you're voters are opposed
to come and demonstrate you want to get
film of it so you can use it in your
next commercial well then why did you go
down to the Freedom Summer and go to
Mississippi and leave ha because people
in Mississippi couldn't vote you've
obviously been waiting to try and catch
me but you're wrong on this I'm hoping
you'd say that civil disobedience and
demonstrations done by Gandhi and Martin
Luther King were on behalf of people who
couldn't vote I went to Mississippi in
the summer of 64 because the Mississippi
black people weren't allowed to vote and
once we were able to get the Voting
Rights Act it was to physically protect
them we went to Mississippi because
black people got beaten up and when
white people from the north came down
they were a little more nervous about
that but what then happened was through
a political pressure
you got the Voting Rights Act and since
the Voting Rights Act came blacks in
Mississippi home sent for white helpers
anymore they vote they go through the
political process there's no black
congressman from Jackson a black mayors
so that's precisely the point if you
don't have the vote if you have no other
option then you have to use direct
action but where you have the ability to
vote and Treach your legislators that's
why the tea party is unfortunately from
my standpoint so much more effective
than occupy I wish it was the other way
around but what Martin Luther King was
doing at the time that he was
assassinated is he was moving into the
Poor People's Party and he was trying to
organize on economics you said you were
talking about money out of politics and
now we know that people the lowest
echelon of income have zero influence
over no that's because that's that's a
self-fulfilling prophecy I wish you
would stop doing tell people that they
have no influence and they won't vote
which there were voter registration
cables that I could play the voted
people will listen to the vote
[Applause]
and not participating in effectively the
green room
it's the summer I'm gone fishing thank
you for Real Time with Bill Maher and
Friday night at 10 past bill and his
guests were questions right after the
show at hbo.com